♪♪
>> THE BATTLE OF BIG IDEAS.
PRESIDENT TRUMP RAMPING UP THE
RHETORIC AND GOING AFTER
DEMOCRATIC RIVALS INCLUDING JOE
BIDEN AFTER A REPORT SAYING THEY
WANT THE FORMER V.P. TO SCALE
BACK HIS SCHEDULE BECAUSE OF HIS
GAFFES.
>> YOU HAVE POCAHONTAS RISING,
KAMALA IS FALLING.
[BOOING]
YOU GOT BETO, HE'S, LIKE, GONE.
I THINK SLEEPY JOE MAY BE ABLE
TO LIMP ACROSS THE FINISH LINE.
BUT TODAY THEY ANNOUNCED THAT
THEY'RE GOING TO CUT WAY BACK ON
HIS APPEARANCES BECAUSE HE IS
SUCH A DISASTER.
YOU HAVE NO CHOICE BUT TO VOTE
FOR ME, BECAUSE YOUR 401-K, DOWN
THE TUBES, EVERYTHING IS GOING
TO BE DOWN THE TUBES.
WHETHER YOU LOVE ME OR HATE ME,
YOU GOT TO VOTE FOR ME.
[LAUGHING]
>> WELL, TRUMP UNLEASHLES THE
ATTACKS, DEMOCRATS TAKE A MUCH
DIFFERENT APPROACH TO TRY TO WIN
THE WHITE HOUSE.
THE "WASHINGTON POST" POINTING
OUT THE CANDIDATES ARE PROMISING
TO OFFSET VOTERS, QUOTE,
ANXIETIES AND WITH A RETURN TO
NORMALCY WITH A PRESIDENT WHO IS
EVERYTHING THEY BELIEVE TRURN IS
NOT.
MEASURED, PREDICTABLE,
RESPONSIBLE.
FOR AT ITS MOST REDUCTIONTIVE,
UNOFFICIAL PLEDGE TO MAKE
AMERICA BORING AGAIN.
SOME OF THE 2020 HOPEFULS VOWING
TO ACT THE OPPOSITE OF TRUMP.
>> I'M NOT DOING CRAZY THINGS
LOOKING FOR VIRAL MOMENT.
>> I SAID IF YOU ELECT ME
PRESIDENT COUNT ON TWO WEEKS
GOING BY WHEN YOU DON'T NEED TO
THINK ABOUT WHAT I'M DOING.
>> I'M JOE BIDEN, I'M RUNNING
FOR.
UNITED STATES, LOOK ME OVER.
YOU'RE LIKELY TO SEE MORE AND
NOT VOTE FOR THE OTHER PERSON.
>> TIRED OF WHAT YOU ARE SEEING.
IT'S TIRING.
>> DANA, I WANT TO ASK YOU ABOUT
THE TWO STRATEGIES.
THE ADVISORS' BELIEF THAT JOE IS
GREAT IN THE MORNING BUT IN THE
OF THE NOON, GETTING TIRED,
THINKING ABOUT SCALING BACK HIS
SCHEDULE.
WHAT DO YOU THINK ABOUT THE
DEMOCRATS TRYING TO BE BORING?
>> I THINK THAT THE STRATEGY OF
HAVING BIDEN DO LESS, IF YOU'RE
WORRIED ABOUT POLL NUMBERS IS
GOOD.
HE HAD MAINTAINED HIS POLL
NUMBERS AT THE HIGHEST LEVEL
UNTIL HE STARTED DOING MORE
APPEARANCES.
THEN AS HE STARTED DOING MORE
APPEARANCES HE STARTED TO SLIP.
ALSO BECAUSE OTHERS ARE RAMPING
THINGS UP.
ELIZABETH WARREN, HER
ORGANIZATION IS REALLY GOOD.
IF THEY THINK IT WILL HELP HIM
BE ABLE TO MAINTAIN UNTIL HE
GETS TO A GENERAL, I DON'T KNOW.
I DON'T THINK IT SPEAKS WELL TO
THE IDEA OF HOW HE WOULD DO MANO
Y MANO AGAINST PRESIDENT TRUMP.
THE QUESTION OF ELECTABILITY IS
ASKED AGAIN.
POLL NUMBERS ARE STAYING HIGH
EVEN THOUGH HE HAS MADE SOME
GAFFS BUT THEY'VE STARTED TO
SLIP.
BEING BORING, I GUESS IN SOME
WAYS, LOOK, THERE'S GOING TO BE
A CHUMPB CHUNK OF PEOPLE, ABOUT
P 5 3 5%, CHANTING FOUR MORE
YEARS ANDN'T GET ENOUGH AND THEY
LOVE IT, CAN'T WAIT FOR THE
PRESIDENT DONE RE-ELECTED.
THEN LIKE 35% SAYING WE'VE GOT
TO HAVE A RETURN TO NORMALCY, WE
CAN'T TAKE THIS ANY MORE.
AND I THINK THE SWUNG VOTERS,
LOVE ME OR HATE ME, YOU KNOW,
YOU HAVE TO CHOOSE ME BECAUSE
THEY'LL SAY IT'S ONLY FOUR MORE
YEARS.
RIGHT?
>> IT FEELS LIKE A LOT LONGER
THAN FOUR YEARS.
HELP, HELP, HELP.
>> WHAT IS THE ALTERNATIVE?
>> YOU WANT TO SAY SOMETHING
ABOUT THE STRATEGIES, JUAN?
>> ON THE FIRST POINT THE
OPPOSITE OF WHAT THE REPUBLICANS
CALL TRUMP DERANGEMENT SYNDROME
THEY ATTACH TO ANYBODY CONCERNED
ABOUT TRUMP, TRUMP ANXIETY
STROME.
SCHOOL JIRNTS AND PSYCHIATRISTS
HAVE SAID PEOPLE ARE ANXIOUS
WITH TRUMP IN OFFICE.
JUST THIS WEEK, TRUMP WENT AFTER
THE FEDERAL RESERVE, HE WENT
AFTER, I THINK, HE ADVISED
ISRAEL TO BUY THOSE TWO
CONGRESSWOMEN, FROM ENTERING
THEIR COUNTRY, NOBODY SAW A
PRESIDENT DO THAT, BAR THEM.
EVEN REPUBLICANS, MARCO RUBIO,
EVEN THE JEWISH PEOPLE, SAYING
NOT A GOOD IDEA.
IT NEVER STOPS WITH THIS GUY.
SO OF COURSE PEOPLE ARE GOING TO
SAY, WE'D LIKE TO GET BACK TO
NORMAL.
>> I DON'T KNOW IF THAT'S AN
INSPIRING MESSAGE.
>> IT'S BIDEN 2020, AMERICA
NEEDS A NAP.
[LAUGHING]
LET'S TALK ABOUT THIS.
>> HOW ABOUT AMERICA NEEDS A
BREAK.
>> I WANT TO ADDRESS THIS AND
I'LL SHOW YOU THE HYPOCRISY IN
THIS IDEA.
BORING APPROACH IS BASED ON A
FACT THAT DONALD TRUMP CAN BE
EXHAUSTING.
HE'S PACKED 12 YEARS INTO THREE
YEARS.
THE RIGHT AND THE LEFT
UNDERSTAND THAT.
NOW THAT DEMOCRATS KNOW HOW WE
FEEL, THEY HATE WAKING UP EVERY
MORNING HAVING TO FAILS THE NEWS
OF TRUMP.
EVERY MORNING THEY HAVE TO DEAL
WITH TRUMP.
WELL THAT'S WHAT IT'S BEEN LIKE
FOR CONSERVATIVE REPUBLICANS FOR
THE PAST 40, 50 YEARS.
MODERN LEFTISM HAS INJECTED
POLITICS INTO EVERY PART OF OUR
LIVES.
SPORTS, ENTERTAINMENT, SEX,
GENDER, OUR KIDS, WE'RE
SUFFOCATING UNDER LEFTISM.
EVERYWHERE, WE WAKE UP, WE'RE
FACED WITH IT.
SO NOW WE FINALLY GOT SOMEBODY
WHO'S THROWING IT BACK THIS YOUR
FACE.
HE SAID OH YOU WANT TO PICK ON
US, SCREW YOU.
IT GOES BACK TO THAT
POLARIZATION MYTH, THESE ARE
POLARIZING TIMES.
ONLY E POLARIZING TIMES, THE
SECOND POLL SHOWED UP, ONLY ONE
POLL, THE LEFT OWNED THE BALL,
THEY OWNED THE STADIUM, THEY
OWNED THE FIELD, ENTERTAINED
ACADEMIA, SOCIAL MEDIA.
NOW A GUY SAYS I'M HERE, I'M THE
OTHER POLL.
SO IT'S POLARIZING.
>> I'M TELLING YOU, THIS IS ALL
GARBAGE, THIS IS ALL GARBAGE.
THEY ARE MAD BECAUSE THEY HAVE
TO FIGHT.
ABOUT TIME.
>> GREAT POINT.
>> BENCHING BIDEN IS JUST THAT,
SCREAMS OF HIM BEING IN TROUBLE
AND HE NEEDS A TIME-OUT.
SO ME I'M A PUBLIC ADMISSION OF
A FAILURE.
HE REMINDS ME OF THE FAMILY
VOLVO WE HAD GROWING UP, 300,000
MILES ON IT, IT'S NOT INSPIRING
ANYBODY, IT'S JUST GETTING YOU
FROM A TO B.
BPT IT PLAYS INTO THE LARGER
CONVERSATION OF ARE DEMOCRATS
ARE GOING TO VOTE WITH THEIR
HEADS IN THE PAST WHERE THEY
WERE PLAYING IT SAFE, IT WAS
DISASTER WITH KERRY AND GORE AND
DUE DAKIS.
OR MAYBE THIS TIME AROUND IT'S
KIND OF A TOSSUP WHAT'S GOING TO
HAPPEN IN THE GENERAL.
IT'S FUNNY PEOPLE LIKE SOUTH
CAROLINA, THEY'RE HOSTING FUND
RAISERS AND SAYING SOMETHING TO
BE SAID FOR TWO WHITE GUYS GOING
AT EACH OTHER, IT'S ABOUT
GETTING THE JUVENILE NARSSIST
OUT.
THEY'RE FREAKING OUT.
MY RESPONSE ABOUT TRUMP IS
EXHAUSTING, ALWAYS IN THE NEWS.
I FEEL LIKE IT'S WHEN PEOPLE SAY
I GO TOO FAST IN LIFE AND SORRY,
NOT SORRY YOU CAN'T KEEP UP.
>> NICELY DONE.
>> I THINK YOU HAD THE RALLY
LAST NIGHT IN WHAT YOU JUST
SAID.
THE FACT IS EVEN AS HE SAYS VOTE
FOR ME IF YOU HATE ME OR LOVELY
AND THE ECONOMY WILL SINK IF YOU
DON'T VOTE FOR ME.
YOU KNOW WHAT THE FOX POLL THIS
WEEK SHOWED TWO-THIRDS OF
AMERICA SAYS HE'S KILLING US
APART AS A COUNTRY.
THAT WAS REAL.
>> THAT WAS A POLL?
>> YEAH.
>> TEARING PEOPLE APART?